[MUSIC]
This is Sharing Your Story Part II,
Putting Pen to Paper.
This is one of our workshop series for
application week.
My name is Wil Torres.
I'm one of the admission officers here at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
And over the course of today,
my hope is we will all get a better
understanding of how writing
fits in the application process,
especially if you're
thinking about the GSB.
So, in session one, so starting your
story, I talked a lot about getting
an understanding for what is your,
quote unquote, big picture.
What's your journey?
What does it look like
if you look backwards?
What were those footsteps?
What did that trail look like?
What was environment around the trail?
Look upwards, what's your North Star?
Be comfortable with all of
those details in spaces.
So that's a lot of detail.
So how do you distill that into
the written parts of the application?
It sounds like it's going to
be a tough situation.
But I hope that by the end of today,
you are going to be inspired to
kind of think deeply,
try different things and see what fits,
what feels good, and pursue those and
allow that to channel and
focus your energy on what
you're putting down on paper.
So that's what we're going to be doing
today, session two, putting pen to paper.
So, a little bit about today's session,
we will be recording it and
posting it to our Youtube channel.
So I definitely recommend
to check that out.
It's one of those hidden gems.
There's a lot of great content both
in terms of admissions as well
as what campus lifelike in lieu
of visiting campus in person.
Sometimes these videos are some of the
best glimpses of the things that happen
and the energy that you're going to
experience during your time at the GSB.
So, over the course of the day,
I'm going to talk a little, the writing.
What does it look like, how does it
fit in with that review process,
the holistic review process
that I've been talking about?
Every session this week, we're
going to talk about content and style.
Notice that I'm not breaking up
our sections into essay one essay
two optional questions.
We will talk about those.
But even this structure is intentional.
My hope is that we are going to think
beyond just what matters most to you
and why.
But think about each opportunity
in that writing landscape as
a chance to tell us
something about yourself.
Definitely going to start talking about
tips, takeaways, tactical, practical.
And I've tried my best to weave in
questions that we've had through the week.
And over the course of my career were the
ones that I've seen rise to the top pretty
frequently, and
embed those into today's session.
So, let's get this going.
Preface, there is a lot
of advice out there,
take everything with a grain of salt.
Take even the advice that I'm giving
you today with a grain of salt.
This is not an end all be all and this
is the way to get into Stanford session.
But rather my hope is to provide different
frameworks, ways for you to think through,
step back and kind of tackle it from
a new direction, if you get stuck.
This is really to empower you and try to
help you self coach through this process.
So, this also,
I can only speak for Stanford.
Some of the tips and recommendations
in all honesty are also mine.
But hopefully these are things that
you can also use throughout your life.
Whether you are applying to school,
or maybe you're applying to a job, or
you just thinking about
what's coming next in life.
Hopefully, some of these things
will come in handy along the way.
So, writing in the holistic
review process.
This is going to be a definition
that you've seen through the week.
Holistic, characterized by comprehension
of the parts of something as intimately
interconnected and
explicable only by reference to the whole.
What that means in the admissions process
at Stanford is that we are taking a look
at everything you submit for us to
really get to know and understand you.
It's not a process where we're looking at
one thing kind of screening from there,
looking at another thing and
passing it through.
But really taking all the pieces
to really understand, okay,
how do these elements of context come
together for us to understand, okay,
here is how this individual's intellectual
vitality, demonstrated leadership
potential, and personal qualities and
contributions come together.
In our evaluation process, it is Is
not a formula, It's not an equation or
algorithm.
There are no benchmarks, cut offs or
quotas, so we're not saying, hey, we need
x amount from this industry or we're only
going to take x amount from that country.
That's not how it works.
We're really looking at you as
an individual, trying to bring together
a talented, dynamic, exciting group of
people to learn and kind of grow together.
No one part of the application
necessarily means more than another.
And I think this is where sometimes
that essay starts to look really,
darkly over your anxiety,
over what can happen next.
It is not a make it or break it piece.
We are using the essays in conjunction
with the other parts of your application
to understand who you are.
We are not grading your written
portions as good or bad.
We're really using those as
an opportunity to learn more about you.
That's one of those things that I
really care about, learning about you.
So when you're out there kind of doing
research, hearing things, talking to
people, and you hear someone say, hey,
this is the essay that got me in.
If I take that step back and
realize, okay,
that's an essay as part of
an application that got them in.
I've been in this line of work long
enough, but I do remember applications.
I do remember people and sometimes I hear
people say that I see them kind of in
newspapers or publications and
I remember those files and
sometimes it's like, all right,
that's a cute thought.
So some people get in
despite their essays, and
some people are unfortunately,
we were unable to admit despite
a really well thought out introspective,
really thought out essay.
So really take it as a whole,
really blowing up those parts.
Admissions recommendations are made on the
evaluation as a application as a whole.
If I didn't have written enough,
let's highlight that last part as a whole.
Okay, intellectual vitality,
demonstrated leadership potential,
personal qualities & contributions.
These are the things that we are looking
for throughout your application.
So if you haven't done so already,
check out the evaluation criteria
section of our admissions webpage.
There's a lot of really great
language to help unpack and
really give you new perspectives for
how to understand these somewhat kind
of mushy like phrases and really see
how they might come to life for you.
So in our application,
that's where we were looking all of
these different pieces come together for
us to get that picture of who you are, how
you're going to show up in that on campus.
When it comes to writing, you're really
going to be focusing on these four parts,
essays, resume, activities,
work history, and optional responses.
Notice that I highlighted that section did
a little bit of kind of shading there to
really highlight it's optional.
We have admitted people who
have not filled those out.
We have admitted people
who have filled them out.
It really all depends on your journey,
the things that you're trying to share and
the information that you
want us to know about you.
So, I'm going to hit pause there for
a second.
If you feel like you have a pretty
good understanding of how
the holistic review process works,
can you jump into the Q&A box,
and type in the name of any animal,
just throw it in there.
I want to make sure that hopefully,
people are getting a sense for
the theme that's happening.
Asama Cz was Canada's elephants,
there's actually no reason
that I chose animals other than
to keep you all on your toes.
If you do have questions about
the holistic review process fix those to
please put them into that Q&A box as well.
I'll go through the questions afterwards
to see, hey, where are other places that I
can work on to make sure we're
able to convey the knowledge and
information that we need to.
So any information, questions, animals,
I love animals, pop them in there.
So, thank you for, [LAUGH] letting
us take that quick timeout.
Now, let's talk writing.
So content like what is it
I should be writing about?
Remember that big picture of who you are?
How do we start to figure out which
details are going to be the most helpful?
So, I often get asked questions and
they fall into a couple of buckets here.
Should I be talking about personal things?
Should I be talking about
professional things?
What's the right balance?
Should I focus on details or
a bigger picture?
The answer I give is surprisingly common
across all of those and it's up to you.
Why this is such an open-ended answer,
is that everybody has their own journey.
For one person, your response might be
informed more by your personal experience.
For someone else that balance might
swing more towards that other direction.
And for me to prescribe some
kind of percentage or balance or
way that you should be
kind of answering these,
I think takes away some of that agency and
really does you a disservice.
But that doesn't mean
we're leaving you hanging.
So, take the questions as you're guide,
think of them as your friends.
We put in a lot of efforts to make sure
that the questions are asking what we're
looking for.
And when really not trying to ask for any
hidden questions it's not a trick at all.
But really, how are we learning about
you through the lens of this question?
So, let's go through that in
a little bit more detail.
Let's give it some little
meat on those bones.
So what are these sections asking?
Here are those kind of major written
portions of the GSB application.
Let's start with the resume and
the activities and work history.
Here we're really trying to understand,
what have you done personally,
what have you done professionally?
And I like to think how
these two work together.
I've often heard people say,
hey, it feels kind of redundant,
there's information that
I'm copying back and forth.
And then I like to step back and
think these are two opportunities for
you to share information with us.
Take a look at those two materials.
Do they necessarily have to say
the exact same details word for word?
Yeah, things like your title or
the times that you worked and
where might be the same.
But there are different types of
information that you can convey using both
pieces.
So if you think about it that way,
use it as an opportunity so
you know think through,
what do I want Stanford to know about me?
Let's do this in a little bit more.
Again, I'm not going to leave you
hanging so what should you include here?
Again, up to you.
By that, I mean,
you're the only one who knows what are the
most meaningful things that you've done?
What are the things that you
find the most important?
What are you proud of?
And then as you think about that,
like, why are you proud of it?
How did you get to that place where
you're able to do those things?
Some of those musings that can come
handy later on as people are curious
to know more about your life.
What are some of the things
that shaped your perspective?
There is a question or
application about, hey,
what perspective do you
bring to the class?
We'll talk a little bit more.
I'm stumbling because I want to make
sure I get that phrasing right, because
the wording is important to help you
understand what we're trying to get to.
And then impact,
we talked a lot about impact, and
that can mean anything like,
how is whatever space you're in.
How's it different from your presence?
What are things like scope,
scale, depth, context?
What are some of those details that
might be handy for us to know about you?
If in doubt, if it's important to you,
it's important to us.
So, let's talk a little bit again,
step back that holistic reminder.
We do not have a preference for where you
worked, what organizations you belong to,
what school you might have gone to.
So it's not about the name or
stature of that organization,
but what are those footprints
that you have left behind?
As you think about that and
connect that with intellectual vitality,
demonstrated leadership potential,
personal qualities and contributions.
All of those things, background agnostic,
context dependent, and
what do I mean by that?
Those three things can pop
up anywhere in your life.
And one of the things that I love about
the Stanford evaluation process is will
recognize and celebrate that
wherever that might be for you.
So maybe it comes with your church
involvement, your mosque, your synagogue.
Maybe it's in a club or organization,
maybe it's something you do at home.
There is a lot of leadership competencies
that you might be expressing in your
home situation as well.
So never underestimate with different
places that you might be making an impact.
That context pieces that the way
that you're, some of these qualities
might manifest is going to look
different depending on where you are.
So leadership might look different if
you are a current college student versus
if you are working and you have done
with your company for nine or ten years.
Just because you're in different places
in your life doesn't mean one is more or
less valuable.
We just understand it looked different,
and that's okay.
We want you to kind of
understand where you are,
because that's where that starting
point for growth is, okay.
Let's talk resume, I know we often
focus our attention on the essays,
but for the GSB application it is
like a standard business resume.
Try to keep it to one
page wherever possible.
That said,
there are some unique circumstances,
extenuating circumstances where maybe
two pages might be appropriate.
So the first one that people tend to
think about is if you've had ten or
more years of work experience.
Another one, sometimes you might
have had publications or a book or
your written articles, a white paper.
And those citations as you write them out,
like who were the authors,
what year was it,
was that journal that takes up space.
And so personally,
I think that's helpful information and
I know our staff does as well.
So sometimes there's instances where
it might be appropriate to go and
have into that second page.
Again, we trust your judgement
there's room for flexibility here,
we're not going to dock you because
you go on to that second page.
But really try your best of one page.
Being succinct and direct and
clear in what you're trying to communicate
is also a skill set that you're going to
need to leverage as a business leader.
So there's no better place to start
practicing that then your resume.
Visual impression, so this is already
trending us into that style and
how do I approach it.
This kind of overlap in that Venn diagram,
but if you're thinking about content,
how much writing should I put in there?
Step back, take a look.
Is it helpful or are you hoarding and
just adding all that detail?
Right, we are humans reading
on the side of the table.
So make sure that as you're writing
things are clear that you do read.
You can definitely shrink margins if you
need to, but sometimes that tiny font or
cramming in a lot of words can make it
really difficult to pull out the critical
information that I should
be learning about you.
We do not have a resume format that we
require or ask you to do necessarily.
Similar to the way you all have
different journeys through life,
sometimes that does necessitate a little
bit of creative license and freedom to
make sure that you're able to convey
it in a way that's appropriate for you.
Some industries might emphasize one thing,
others might emphasize another.
We want to make sure you're able to kind
of speak your truth in
all of these spaces.
So I have a little exercise here.
I actually really love doing resumes.
This is a thing that has
come about pretty recently.
I think it's really fun.
So we're going to play a game,
it's called who do you know more about?
We have two individuals, all right,
individual A and individual B.
A manages an aquatic conservation program,
that is that bullet point on their resume.
Person B in that same bullet point space,
created a public private
action plan that studied seven
fish species from extinction.
This might be a little obvious, and
I don't want to be too facetious with it,
but I thought it would be kind
of fun to throw up a poll.
So I'm going to put that out there.
We're going to launch it.
Who are you learning more about
from these one or two lines?
Okay, it seems like it's
a pretty clear answer.
And there's a couple folks
that are putting in A,
which is fine as well, [LAUGH].
My point with this is there are ways for
you to describe the same job.
When I made this example,I actually
have the same person in mind.
And this is something that I often see in
resumes, so I'll go ahead and stop this.
Thank you for entertaining that thought.
But, When you're in your resume,
what's that bullet point doing?
Is it describing what you
do versus what did you do?
There's a slight nuance there.
Sometimes when you're describing,
these are the things that I do.
It's more of a job description versus,
hey, here are the things that I have done.
What are some of those impacts?
That's when you're starting
to see if it's quantifiable,
that's when the numbers come into play.
So really try to think about impact and
how you have left those organization
different or changed them.
And that might be one way for
you to think about, okay,
how can I get maximum mileage out of
that limited real estate on my resume?
And again, each one of you has a,
Different format.
Just ensure that it's clear,
easy to read, and
that the things that you want us to
know about you can take those away.
All right, now let's get into
the essays and the optional responses.
I know there is a lot of questions, myths.
This is where a lot of
myth busting happens.
And so let's go here right,
let's get deep, let's get in the weeds.
So, let's start with the essays.
What matters most to you and why?
And why Stanford?
Earlier I talked about letting
these questions be your guide.
And notice, they are not descriptive.
They are not asking you for what matters
most to you in a business context.
It really is,
what matters most to you and why?
I'd like to encourage all of
you to emphasize and why?
Because that is the question,
that's what we're asking.
There is a difference between
what matters most to you and
here's evidence for it,
versus here's what matters to me.
And here's that introspection and
reflection that helped me really
understand who are you because of?
We did an exercise in sharing your story
one where we listed different things and
kind of talked to them as individuals
saying, because of you I am.
And really helping you impact how those
instances might have impacted who you are.
And that's where that what matters
most to you and why comes from.
Dean Moss talks about a body of research
that says some of the most successful
leaders out there are the ones who lead
from a place of mission, and values, and
purpose.
What are yours?
This internal dialogue that you
are engaging with in this question is also
going to be reflective of some of that
internal dialogue, that world of feedback
that you're going to be engaging with at
the GSB in that leadership curriculum.
Why should someone follow you?
Draw that attention inward, and hopefully
this question is doing that as well.
Why Stanford?
Two words, so
many places you can go with them.
Maybe the subtext here is why Stanford for
you?
Center yourself in all of the responses.
Some folks might,
the mission might resonate for them.
For others,
it's because their ability to explore and
pivot into another place is going to
be facilitated by the stuff here.
We have no expectations.
We don't think one rationale is more
important or compelling than another.
What I want to learn about is what are
your motivations for coming here, right?
And so that's where that comes from.
I want to learn about you.
Okay, there are the optional
responses as well.
And so where these came from,
I think helps illustrate how we're
thinking about the essays and
these responses as a way to learn about
you kind of in a really interesting way.
So what we found in the past is that
what matters most to you and why essay,
people were putting in their
accomplishments in there.
Which definitely things to be proud of,
but they didn't always necessarily connect
with the things that mattered to them.
So it almost felt like they were
shoving a round peg into a square hole.
So that's where these optional responses
came in, especially that impact one.
We want to create a separate place
because we do want to know about that.
We do want to know about
the impact you've created.
But we also want you to be able to answer
the questions kind of with honesty and
truth, right and
not have to try to squeeze or
kind of mix things up just
to get all of these bits in.
So what are these questions?
There we go.
Think about times you've created a
positive impact, whether in professional,
extracurricular, academic,
or other settings.
What was your impact?
What made it significant to you or others?
Pretty clear cut here,
we're asking you directly.
And one of the things here is that you
don't necessarily have to use flowy prose.
Take how much space you have and
how much runway as a clue to, hey,
maybe this is where I can be more direct.
Maybe I'm just giving the facts so
that they know kind of right away,
what's going on.
What's the context, scope, scale?
Why is this meaningful and significant?
The second one, tell us about a time
within the last three years when your
background influenced your participation
in a situation, interaction, or project.
Again, very clear about kind of
the context and circumstances that were
asking you, but also very open
ended when we say background.
No, that could be anything
about who you are.
Again, in session one of starting
your story, we practiced and
went through a couple different exercises,
so
that you might be able to think
through okay, hey, who am I?
And what does that mean as I think about
both business school and life beyond?
And that could be one place to go if
you'd like a little bit of inspiration,
if you want to go through
this optional question.
Okay, I'm going to call this
section quick questions.
So this is actually drawn
from things this week.
And we're going to speed through this and
hopefully it'll cover some
of the questions that you
have in the Q&A box, right?
So do my essays have to connect?
What if I talk about the same things?
Will it be redundant?
We're going to go through these one by
one and we're going to hammer them out.
Do my essays have to connect?
The answer is no.
Sometimes the things that
matter the most to you,
aren't the reasons that you want to
go to Stanford, and that's fine.
We want you to use those spaces in a way
that makes the most sense for you.
What if I talk about the same things,
will it be redundant?
So you can talk about the same thing,
especially if you're coming
from it from different angles.
There might be details about maybe
a bullet point in your resume,
some of that contextual situational,
kind of those ripple effects.
That you might want to include
in your impact questions or
somewhere in your essay.
Or maybe there is something you
refer to in your essay, but
more in that personal sense.
But there's also impacts and
repercussions of it.
Maybe that's where you add additional
detail in the impact side.
So really thinking beyond just one part of
the application to really understand like,
hey, these are different ways
I can add depth and nuance,
even if it's about a single thing.
Sometimes those single things can be
really meaningful, both for you and
the people around you.
How vulnerable is too vulnerable?
This is up to you, this one is
a little bit, again, up to you.
I would say, what am I learning
about you through this process?
Again, it's less about why and
more about the so what, who are you?
What am I learning?
I really appreciate this question,
I get asked it a lot.
My own personal request is you
only need to add the amount
of detail to let us know what is going on.
I really appreciate that because you never
know who was reading on the other side and
you want to be thoughtful to not
potentially trigger other experiences they
might have had.
So just be thoughtful, that goes for
the details that you're adding as well.
Give us enough, so that we understand
the situation and then focus on you.
What if my story is complicated?
Sometimes this goes hand in
hand with these other pieces.
The additional information
section can be your best friend.
Maybe it is a term during college,
where you had extreme health crisis.
Maybe it was something else
going on in your life.
Maybe it is some of these extenuating
circumstances that inform you something
that you've written, but don't necessarily
fit in with the flow that you have.
Use that additional information space that
judiciously, but include any relevant
bits of information that you think we need
to know, so that we really understand you.
Bullet points are your friends here,
this is not additional essay,
it's additional information.
Be concise, again,
let us know what you think we need to,
so that we really understand
your circumstances.
How much explaining is
too much explaining?
I kind of refer to this in some
of our previous responses.
Am I learning more about you?
Or am I learning about the situation?
In the holistic review process,
I want to know about you.
And who will see my writing?
So the admissions staff and you are the
only people who are going to see it.
And whoever you share it with personally,
we don't share this with faculty,
is not part of the evaluation process.
We are trained professionals,
not even your alumni,
interviewers are going to see it.
All they see is your resume, and
you know exactly what goes on there.
So know that this is a safe, confidential
space that if you do want to go somewhere
vulnerable, or if you're talking about
something, maybe for the first time,
if it's something that maybe
the world doesn't know about you, but
you want to discuss it with us, you can.
And we're not going to be
sharing that with anybody.
Okay, so that was quick questions.
How do I stand out from the crowd?
This is that next question
I get all the time.
So center yourself,
I talked a lot about that.
Embrace your journey and
be true to your reasons and rationale.
Discuss the things that are meaningful
to you just if I had a quarter for
every time I said the word you,
[LAUGH] in these presentations.
Hopefully that's an indicator for
where we're going with like,
what we're hoping we're getting out of
this journey with you, so and think deep.
This is where those
interesting bits come out.
This is where,
even if we all say something like family,
the way we've engaged with it and
your own experience with family is
going to be different from mine.
It's going to be different
from everybody on this call.
So really go there and understand
the whos and hows of what you are.
So we're going to do a quick exercise.
You might have done this with me before or
somewhere else.
If you have done it in the context
of the GSB application,
try it with a different topic.
But what we're going to do is
I'm going to ask you a question.
I'm going to turn my camera off.
So if you want to grab pen and
paper, so you can jot something down,
open up another browser or just think
along, I'm going to turn my camera off, so
that I don't distract you too much.
I want you to be able
to get into that zone.
I'll give you reminders and
cues for what to do next, and
then we'll take it from there.
Don't need to think about it too hard.
Just really the first
thing that comes to mind.
What matters to you?
Lowering the stakes on this question,
it doesn't even have to be what matters
most to you, but what matters to you?
Just give you a couple of seconds so
that you can jot something down there,
and think your way through it, all right?
Now, let's get to the fun bit.
Why?
I'll give you about a minute, so
that you can jot your thoughts down and
really start to unpack
your first response.
Start to wrap that thought.
Take a deep breath,
give yourself a moment,
because I'm going to ask
you another question.
Why that?
You just give me what matters to you, why?
Think, if there was a child asking you,
sometimes they're asking why, why, why?
Bring that childlike sense of
curiosity to this questions
Go ahead, start wrapping that thought up.
Take another deep breath.
Let that one out.
Take me one level deeper, why that?
So, go ahead and complete that file.
I'm going to continue because we have some
more content that I really want to share
with you all.
But if you get stuck and
you're just curious and
you want to try something different,
try this.
Continue to ask yourself again.
And then ask yourself again
get down to that fifth, why?
Usually even by the third, fourth, fifth,
why those are when you're going to be
talking about things that
only you can talk about.
And you don't necessarily have to
put those things in the application.
But as it broadens your
understanding of things
maybe there are a lot of
things that matter to you.
Maybe try try this exercise and
see is there a fundamental
common theme across them?
You might be surprised at what you find,
right?
So we don't have a preference for
how you approach this.
We don't have a preference for
what you share.
We just want you to share.
What is most important to you and why?
I know there's a lot of questions here
about the spirit of the question and
we did talk about that briefly.
Whether or not to do a series of short
kind of responses or kind of one cohesive,
big thing.
Again, that is up to you.
We trust you to use that space to
really reflect what you want us to know
about you.
So I want to empower you to take
that space and make it your own.
To unpack this exercise
a little bit further,
this is something we did yesterday.
Again referring back to sharing yourself
story one, starting your story.
Where you can use this as
an exercise to think about, okay,
what am I learning about myself from
that thing that I just thought about?
What can I do next with it?
So splitting this up into a process and
outcomes.
Was that the answer you expected?
From there, you can ask things like,
why did this answer go that way?
Did it take a left turn?
Did it take a U turn?
Did it stay, straight on track to
what you thought it was going to be?
If it wasn't different, how?
Maybe the track still went in
the same direction generally, but
there's a couple of wiggles in there.
What does that mean for
how you're thinking about that?
And I think this part's also important.
How did you feel?
Registering the way your body responds
can often help you understand, okay?
We're places that could be interesting to
go and explore a little further right?
And that spirit of the self discovery
maybe going somewhere a little
uncomfortable and
going into that personal stretch zone.
So when or where was it was it harder?
And then on the other side of
the spectrum, where was it easier?
Where did you find that energy and
where did that let you up?
Because that could be another area to
chase if you want to figure out okay,
maybe what should I be writing about?
So, next if you want to do
this as a further exercise,
there's multiple steps that you
could do with any of these,
either try writing for
full two minutes and just keep that.
Choose one of these questions, right for
the full two minutes answering it.
want to challenge right for a full five
minutes, just keep writing and don't stop.
Another version knowing that some folks
are actually verbal processors, maybe
talk through it, talk to somebody answer
them, talk to a screen, talk to the wall.
If you would like to
talk to a friendly face,
please feel free to stop this video
at any time that I'm smiling.
I will always be there for
you to listen as you practice this.
So, shifting over into style,
tips and best practices,
we're just going to go straight there.
If you're planning for the future,
maybe you are thinking maybe one or
two years away, maybe just not sure.
You can still prepare.
So practice and
practice developing your written voice.
And that just means practice.
Write things down.
There are definitely journals out there
that have built in questions that you
respond to maybe have a personal kind
of blog or something you do every day,
practice.
It's going to get easier and easier.
I know for many of us out there, there
might be cultural familiar community,
talking about yourself might
feel a little uncomfortable.
And in the application process,
we want to know about you like if
that hasn't been clear, yet
I want you to embrace that and
take his invitation to really
focus on yourself in this.
Allow yourself to have that exploration.
Make time for that introspection.
And do it all read read anything.
I am a big proponent of reading.
That's how you absorb and
see how other people use language.
From there that can often help how help
inform the way that you write type
and think.
Once you're in the weeds of the
application, there's a couple of things
here that I would definitely highlight
as well consider your audience.
You might be an expert in your field and
we have seen a whole lot of fields.
And you might be doing something
that might be very niche.
But you can translate some of those
things that anybody can understand so
that if you're talking to
a stranger if your grandmother or
someone understanding what you do.
You could explain it to them and
they could say, yeah, that makes sense,
I get it.
It's possible and remember,
think about who is on the other side.
I would also include this as
sometimes there might be slaying or
when you're thinking,
how informal can I be?
This is still a business
school application,
you want to put
a professional foot forward.
But that doesn't necessarily mean
everything has to be formal language.
It doesn't have to have
necessarily a formal structure.
The what matters why essay in particular
lends itself to a little bit of creative
license.
If that's where you want to go.
If you would like to convey
it in a intro body, body,
body close, end of structure,
and that works for you, go there.
All right, so just know that
this audience professional foot
forward when one is
technical to technical,
I refer to that a little bit acronyms
will also fall under this umbrella.
So, make sure you spell things out or
are there other ways to communicate what
it is especially if it's very important.
If there's not, and it's very important,
additional information could
be a place to go, but don't use
additional information as a glossary for
acronyms so
that you could save space later on.
You want people to know what's
going on in any single spot of your
application to the extent possible.
I mentioned you don't have to
write the same way in each one.
What matters most and the optional
responses are a great example of that.
Where what matters most you can use
a little bit more freeform language be
a little bit more informal.
You can be more direct and
really just tell us what the details are.
In some of these spaces where
you have less space, and
through it all the best voice is your own.
And that's why I said
earlier like practice,
write in a way that feels natural to you.
There's a difference between
constructive feedback.
Stanford is a huge place for feedback,
as long as you're that final thought and
intent an idea is yours.
If you become too, if other
people's ideas start to cloud that,
if there are other contributions
there other than your own,
that's where it becomes
inappropriate cocci.
And sometimes that's the place where
we actually you lose some of the most
interesting and kind of transparent,
authentic genuine elements of who you are.
So, feedback great.
Be true to yourself.
Use your own voice and
trust your judgment through this.
Okay, more tips and takeaways
because I am all about that today.
If you need a push writing,
mix it up, try walking.
Sometimes walking can help jog your memory
or jog your [LAUGH] Creative juices.
Pun not originally intended but
I'm going to go with it.
I'm someone who processes by movement,
so lean into that.
For some folks speaking might be better.
Take a recorder, record your voice, use
a transponder, type it down afterwards.
Whatever works for you, go there.
Resist the urge to copy and
paste and hear not so much because,
a name might be lifted from one
application to another, but
each school has a different spirit, energy
and thing that might draw you to them.
So, if you're writing,
a fresh response for that school,
that helps you channel that and
ensure that it doesn't feel generic or
something that can be applied anywhere.
And that's going to be of
great service both to you,
as well as whatever admission
officer is reading it afterwards.
That'll help them see you as
someone in their community.
Again, reinforcing the idea it's
not how quote unquote good or
bad your writing is
because that's subjective.
What I'm looking in your reading for
what can I learn in your writing?
What I read in your writing for,
is what can I learn about you?
And that is where can have
that maximum value is.
What you want us to know?
Is always going to be better than
what you think I want to know, okay?
And this goes for both how you convey and
what you tell me about your past
experiences in your resume.
What and
how you write in any of your responses.
I do not have any preferences here?
You have ownership.
I know there's a lot of questions in
the chat in the q & a about do we have
preferences and how we approach things?
And the answer is no.
We want to make sure you have
enough license, enough landscape,
a blank canvas to really
let us know who you are.
And I know that can be
both kind of liberating or
terrifying depending on
the way you approach it.
But I think it can be a great
opportunity to stand up, own that story.
If in doubt, if you're not
sure where something is going.
Maybe it feels like something has gone
off track but you're not sure what it is.
Ask yourself.
So what?
Why am I even writing about this?
What is the message I'm
trying to convey here?
Does this actually sound like something
else I've written in this kind of
piece here.
So, can I change it?
Should I change it?
So, what?
That can be an incredibly powerful
tool to check yourself step back and
look at things from fresh lenses.
I'll say it once, I'll say it again,
be true to your journey.
Yours is the one that we want to learn
about yours is the one we want to
hear from.
And I'm going to leave you with these
parting words before we jump into this
q & a box.
Everyone has a different
journey to Stanford,
everyone has their own
journey to Stanford.
So, will you take that,
let that settle in, let that simmer,
if you haven't done so
already, and of course,
I'm going to go into this plug face
to mix it up from left field good.
If check out my Stanford.nba, this can
be a great place for you to learn more.
There's an application tracker and
so, great tool but
another great tool that I
really enjoy is that q & a box,
so that's where I'm going to head to next.
So, I refer to it here,
there's a question,
what if there is multiple things
that are important to you?
Does it have to be one thing, like I said,
there's a creative license for
some people.
Yeah, it might be a lot of things.
Is there something that encapsulate that?
Technically, the word,
the phrase one thing suggests one thing.
So again, however you want to
approach this, I have no preference.
Take it around what
matters that you write?
It doesn't even say what's
one thing that matters.
Hey, go with a question.
Does admissions view non standard
writing say inner woven poetry for
example, use it judiciously.
I have some instance
where quotes excerpts,
pro something more creative
has been inserted.
But you also don't want to have
something dominated by that.
This is not a creative writing
program that you're applying to,
as long as you're answering the question
and I know what I'm getting out of it.
And I know what your responses the kind
of that's the core of the style and
the extra elements that you
want to put into there.
If you do decide to go a little
bit more creative, this might be
an instance when you think about,
also showing that you can be direct and
clear in other spaces of your application,
right.
So, even thinking about,
this is how really meaningful for me and
I want to express myself this way, and
I can also talk this way up to you.
So, from Nikita mentioned,
when I referred so
you never know if something might
be triggering for someone else.
Sometimes there might be details,
sometimes if they're very graphic details
about instances where there might have
been violence or situations like that.
If someone is reading that, or hearing
that, it might bring them to that space,
and also make them feel uncomfortable
It's okay to write about
difficult instances in your life.
What I would say is keep it
at the level of detail so
that we understand what happens you don't
have to go into that graphic element.
But, just enough so that we know and
that is just a general kind of guideline
that I offer to people you don't have
to take it but remember, this is
almost like a one page conversation
that we're having with each other.
And you also want that person on the other
side to feel comfortable as they're
reading yours so,
I would also use that as a plug for
if I'm talking about
something controversial.
Don't be controversial to get
a rise out of someone to get their
attention it's about what am I
learning about you from this process
hopefully that was helpful I know that
can be a kind of fine line to draw,
but again trust your best judgment there.
Question from Daniel from my exercise
is it more appropriate than your or
should you be for primary job?
So how much detail like when were
asking about what is your primary job
responsibilities?
That is one where I would say, we're
asking about your job responsibilities, so
that could definitely be where you put
manages aquatic cultivation program?
But in terms of like Blitz, I was more
referring to like bullet points on
your resume, because that's where we want
to know what you did and even an impact
questions read you got it right when
you're interpreting that question.
All right?
And then in terms of the process, and I
want to kind of come back to the holistic
review process and I know that
this has been a recurring theme.
It doesn't really matter which part of
the application we're reading first,
because we're going to be looking at every
single piece of it together to understand
who you are, no one part is that
gateway piece, not even an interview.
Right?
It can feel like sometimes the interview
was a make it or break it but
that's not how it works we'll hear
back from the interviewer and
then we'll look at that kind of report
in conjunction with everything that
you submitted same goes for
this application.
So if you think your way through it,
we want to know you threw it out so
take yourself out from that mindset,
take ownership of the things that you
can do here and please know that we
are reading with your best intent in mind
we are reading to admit not to deny.
And so with that, thank you so much for
joining us hopefully this was helpful,
hopefully didn't inundate
you with too many details.
If you have questions, we have many
more events both this week and
throughout the summer above and feel
free to send our office any questions,
comments that you might
have as well as feedback.
It helps us provide events like this that
can be as helpful for you as possible.
Thank you, stay safe.
[MUSIC].